- [Voiceover] We're already looked at
Faraday's law in some detail.
It showed us that if we have some
loop of conductor and we have a change
in magnetic flux over
time through the surface
defined by that loop, it's going to induce
an EMF through that loop which will cause
a current to start to
circulate through that loop
and that current, of
course, will be dependent
on the actual resistance of the conductor.
And there's many ways
that we've already seen
of having a change in magnetic flux.
One, you can have a change
in the magnetic field.
It could be a change in its magnitude
and, or it's orientation.
You could have a change in the shape
of the actual loop of conductor.
If its area increases or decreases,
that will change the flux.
Remember, the flux is just your,
the component of the magnetic field
that is perpendicular to the surface.
If you took the average of that times
the area of the surface.
And then the other way that we're going
to study in this video is
inducing an electromotive force
by changing it, not the shape of the loop
and not the magnetic field but by changing
the orientation of the loop.
And in particular, we're
going to have the loop rotate.
So let's think about this.
So I have this loop here.
It's connected to this axle
and I'm going to rotate it
in a, I'm going to rotate
it in a clockwise direction
through this constant magnetic field.
You can see it's constant.
All of the magnetic field vectors
I've just sampled'em at
different points in the field.
They're all pointing straight
up and I've drawn them
so that they all have the same magnitude.
Now we'd appreciate is as we rotate this,
the angle between the magnetic field
and the surface is changing
and right from this point,
as we rotated this clockwise direction,
the component of the magnetic field
that is perpendicular to the
surface is going to increase.
Now what am I talking about?
Well, let's look at it
from this point of view.
Let's look at it from the point of view
of the actual loop of wire,
so from this point of view
the magnetic field is at some angle.
I can draw that angle here
so, you know, whatever angle,
it's a little hard to see,
whatever angle this is,
we could say that is that angle here
and as we rotate the
entire loop, it's attached
to some type of an axle here,
in a clockwise direction.
What is going to happen to this angle?
Well, after let's say delta
T, let's say we're just
rotating it a constant
rate, we're going to have
the magnetic, so after
we've rotated a little bit,
the magnetic field of vector is going
to look something like that.
So it's the component
that is perpendicular
to the surface was what
we care about for flux,
it's going to go from being
like this, it's gonna go
from being like that to going to being,
to being like this, to being like this.
So at least for this
point of the rotation,
for this point of the rotation till we get
to the flat, until we
get to the flat point,
until we have our loop
being completely flat,
the component of our magnetic field
that is perpendicular is going to increase
which is going to have,
so we're going to have
an increase in flux over that time.
So if we have an increase
in flux over that time
as we rotate up, at least
until we get to the flat point,
what is going to happen?
Well, we're going to induce a current
and then we just have to think about what
is the orientation of the current?
So we want to have a current that
will induce a magnetic field that will
go against the change
in flux so the current
should induce a magnetic field that is,
if our flux, at least for
that part of the rotation
is increasing in the upwards direction,
if we're from the point
of view of this loop,
then we need to create a magnetic field
that is acting against that.
So magnetic field that
is acting against that
or we need to, we're
ready to induce a current
that induces a magnetic field that acts
against that change in flux.
So, how do I, what type of current
would induce a magnetic field like that?
So I'll just use the
right-hand rule, my fingers
would go in the direction of these,
of the magnetic field, so my fingers
and I have to use my right hand,
so my fingers are gonna
go in that direction,
so my right hand, my thumb,
my thumb would go in this direction.
So that is going to be the direction
of the current that is induced.
So the whole point of me showing you this,
is that there's multiple ways to have
a change in magnetic flux and there's
multiple ways to induce a current.
And this one is particularly interesting
because it lets you or we
can start to think about,
wow, I could turn, I could
turn a mechanical rotation
into an induced current and
this is, this basic principle
although they wouldn't use
such a simple loop like this,
is exactly how electric generators work.
They're actually, in some ways,
the reverse of an electric motor.
An electric motor has a current
that causes something to rotate.
Here, we're having something rotate
causing a current to
form and that's actually
what we have happening when you look
at something like windmills or
when you look at hydroelectric generators.
Right over here, this windmill, the wind
is going to cause these
blades to turn around
and then inside, inside
of this little place
right over here, you're going
to have a more fancy version
of this rotating which is
going to induce a current.
The magnetic field isn't
going to be exactly like this.
It's going to be a more
sophisticated mechanism
but it's the same underlying principle.
It's just Faraday's law at work.
Same thing with hydroelectric generator,
you're using the potential energy
of the flowing water to turn an axle
and then that helps us
generate electricity
by the exact same principle.